[Música]
la situación humanitaria empeora en
ucrania según la onu los muertos por la
guerra son miles más de los reportados y
la oim estima en más de 8 millones los
desplazados internos mientras tanto el
asedio ruso continuó este martes con
ataques a odessa y un nuevo intento por
tomarse la planta de acceso postal en
marjah
la organización mundial de la salud
calificó como insostenible la estricta
política de 'cero kobe de implementada
por el gobierno de china y por la que
millones de personas se encuentran
confinadas beijing por su parte dice que
abandonar este enfoque supondría más de
un millón de muertes en el país
asesinan en colombia al reconocido
fiscal paraguayo marcelo pecci
especializado contra el crimen
organizado según información preliminar
sujetos a bordo de una moto acuática lo
sorprendieron mientras se encontraba en
una playa cerca de cartagena donde
celebraba su luna de miel
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz empezamos con noticias
de ucrania la misión de monitoreo de
derechos humanos en el país dijo que los
muertos son miles más que los 3.300
reportados en 11 semanas de conflicto la
organización internacional de las
migraciones dijo que ya hay más de 8
millones de desplazados internos y casi
6 millones de refugiados informe de
marina sardenya
el drama humanitario césar ceban ucrania
en la semana 11 de hostilidades y
ataques indiscriminados del ejército
ruso naciones unidas dice que las
víctimas civiles superan por miles a las
más de 7000 reportadas por el propio
organismo entre heridos y fallecidos en
total hasta la fecha hemos corroborado 7
mil 61 víctimas civiles con tres mil 381
muertos y tres mil 680 heridos en todo
el país desde el inicio del ataque
armado de la federación rusa las cifras
reales son mayores y estamos trabajando
para corroborar cada uno de los
incidentes
las cifras representan un agujero negro
especialmente en ciudades como mariupol
dado que los incesantes bombardeos del
kremlin impiden de los organismos
internacionales para esclarecer las
violaciones de derechos humanos
cometidas durante más de dos meses de
asedio según las autoridades locales al
menos 100 civiles continúan atrapados en
el último reducto de resistencia
ucraniana la acería de accesos tal y
miles más en las inmediaciones de la
arrasada urbe
debemos de entender que en mariupol hay
más de 100 mil civiles que están
esperando que se les dé la oportunidad
de salir y que tengan no sólo el deseo
sino también la oportunidad de salvar
sus vidas por lo tanto instó a todos a
unirse y a no rendirse en esta situación
tan difícil
hospitales escuelas o teatros que son
refugio han sido atacados la
organización mundial de la salud
denunció la muerte de al menos tres mil
personas por falta de acceso a sus
tratamientos médicos almost to handle
con casi 200 ataques sanitarios
verificados y documentados por lado
meses sobre el terreno ucrania es
testigo del mayor y más rápido asalto al
sistema sanitario a su personal y a sus
pacientes en space la emergencia
humanitaria se traduce también en el
número de desplazados internos más de 8
millones de ucranianos huyeron de sus
hogares para proteger sus vidas el 63
por ciento son mujeres
6 millones han salido del país más de 8
millones de personas han sido
desplazadas internamente en ucrania
necesitan desesperadamente dinero en
efectivo medicinas y refugio por su
parte moscú continúa negando ataques a
la población civil y califica su
invasión como una operación militar
especial mientras tanto las tropas del
kremlin continúan su ofensiva en el
donbass y se han reportado bombardeos
contra obesa el principal puerto
ucraniano en el mar negro según el
comando operativo del sur ucraniano al
menos una persona murió y otras cinco
resultaron heridas en los ataques
lanzados por el ejército ruso contra la
ciudad costera
y el director de la organización mundial
de la salud desde los gebre jesús
cuestionó la política de covite 0
implementada por el gobierno chino y
bajo la cual se han combinado a millones
de personas en varias zonas del país
especialmente en las últimas semanas con
rebrotes en centros urbanos su
declaración según dijo se da teniendo en
cuenta el comportamiento del virus y lo
que se anticipa en el futuro sin embargo
desde beijing defendieron su enfoque
advirtieron que este sigue siendo
esencial para vencer la pandemia y que
dejarlos supondría la muerte de más de
1.5 millones de personas
louis
hemos discutido este tema con expertos
chinos y les hemos indicado que la
aproximación no será sostenible y
considerando el comportamiento del virus
creo que un cambio sería muy importante
tan considering the beaver of the
wailers fighting school river important
y en españa' médicos y hospitales de
madrid iniciaron hoy una huelga
indefinida en contra de la temporalidad
laboral de los trabajadores de la salud
se quejan de que trabajaron arduamente
durante la emergencia sanitaria provoca
por el 19 pero que aún persiste la
precariedad laboral desde madrid'
nuestra corresponsal marina colorado con
los detalles
a partir de hoy 10 de mayo los médicos
especialistas de hospitales públicos de
madrid están en huelga indefinida piden
que el gobierno de la región acabe con
la alta temporalidad que sufre el sector
que afecta a más de la mitad de la
plantilla y al 82% de quienes trabajan
en urgencias aunque pueda parecer una
jornada normal a mis espaldas más de
11.000 sanitarios estaban convocados a
la huelga sin embargo los servicios
mínimos establecidos por el gobierno de
madrid del 100% en servicios críticos y
urgentes y del 50% en otras
especialidades han hecho muy difícil que
todos puedan acceder a su derecho a
hacer huelga pese a que hace tan sólo
cinco meses entró en vigor en españa una
reforma laboral que pretendía terminar
precisamente con los contratos
temporales y aunque la medida ya está
dando resultados favorables en otros
sectores en el médico aún no se ha
beneficiado desde el propio ámbito
sanitario lo califican como la mayor
empresa de trabajo temporal de españa'
con médicos que llevan décadas
encadenando un contrato temporal tras
otro los médicos piden que los aplausos
recibidos cada día durante la pandemia
del coi
lleguen ahora en apoyo a una huelga para
mejorar el sistema sanitario público de
la capital de españa por otro lado hoy
también se activó la línea 0 24 de
prevención del suicidio que es la mayor
causa de muerte no natural en españa' y
la principal causa de muerte en jóvenes
antes sólo existían iniciativas locales
o sectoriales pero no un servicio
público esta línea de atención a la
conducta suicida se ha financiado
gracias a los fondos de la unión europea
en noticias de américa latina- paraguay
está conmocionada por el caso del
reconocido fiscal especializado contra
el crimen organizado marcelo pecci que
fue asesinado en colombia
pezzi se encontraba en la isla de barú
cerca de la ciudad de cartagena donde
disfrutaba de su luna de miel al lado de
su esposa aunque aún se investigan los
hechos medios colombianos informan que
hombres armados a bordo de una moto
acuática lo sorprendieron con varios
impactos de bala el presidente paraguayo
mario abdo benítez condenó el suceso
seguir en la lucha contra el crimen
organizado en el latín esto es muy
doloroso muy duro he conversado con el
presidente iván duque por teléfono que
se comprometió conmigo para darnos todo
nuestro apoyo para resolver el caso para
buscar a los responsables
también he conversado con el gobierno
americano con respecto a eso quienes
también a través de colombia van a
apoyar y bueno ahora me voy a visitarle
a la fiscala general hablo en ecuador
tras el motín del lunes en la cárcel de
bellavista santodomingo que dejó 44
fallecidos cabecillas de organizaciones
criminales fueron trasladados a otras
prisiones de máxima seguridad en un
intento por calmar la violencia mientras
el país de nuevo debe hacerle frente a
su crisis carcelaria para el análisis
está con nosotros mario pazmiño
consultor internacional en seguridad y
defensa ex director de inteligencia de
ecuador y catedrático de la universidad
unidades en colombia maría bienvenido
france24 la crisis carcelaria en ecuador
no es una noticia nueva porque se siguen
presentando estos hechos tan violentos y
cuál es la respuesta al hacinamiento y a
la medida de aseguramiento
presionándoles una buena tarde para
todos los televidentes el tema aquí es
básicamente que el estado perdió el
control del primer organizado desde
mucho tiempo atrás y especialmente en el
control de los centros carcelarios donde
existen dos factores el 1 es la
altísimos niveles de corrupción y el
segundo la proliferación de mega bandas
que están articulando desde los centros
carcelarios una dinámica de violencia
permanente hacia los centros urbanos eso
es lo que se ve reflejado al momento en
el escenario nacional
a esto se le tiene que sumar dos
factores importantes en uno que es que
estas organizaciones del crimen
organizado locales están comenzando a
mutar hacia lo que se denominan carteles
de primera generación o micro carteles y
también a otro factor el estado no ha
podido hasta la presente fecha manejar
un control eficiente sobre los
diferentes entes personales en qué
medidas están las cárceles preparadas
para los motines por qué es tan difícil
para la fuerza pública retomar y control
es sumamente difícil porque el estado no
tiene el control de los centros
carcelarios por un lado y por otro lado
en que el ingreso de armamento a los
centros carcelarios es una actividad
permanente en las diferentes cárceles
del país esto no se ha podido controlar
lamentablemente la corrupción es la que
prima al interior de los centros
carcelarios y está dificultando la tarea
del estado para poder atender
eficientemente la acción y la actividad
que tiene que cumplir la fuerza pública
al interior de los centros capilares no
se ha podido controlar hasta el momento
estos centros carteras y cómo va la
política para intentar eliminar el
hacinamiento
el tema del hacinamiento es uno de los
factores importantes y más que todo se
está pidiendo a la justicia ecuatoriana
que se haga cargo directamente de la
responsabilidad porque cerca de 16.000
privados de libertad no tienen al
momento sentencia ejecutoriada entonces
se convirtió esto en un negocio perverso
por parte de la justicia ecuatoriana que
trata bajo todo el concepto de sacar un
rédito a esta estacionamiento y a esta
cantidad de detenidos que tiene allá
esperando que tengan el dinero necesario
para poder comprar su libertad que es
una cosa completamente desastrosa en el
tema de seguridad y en el tema de
justicia mario pazmiño gracias por
acompañarnos aquí en france 24 y
cambiamos de tema y finalizamos en
colombia porque se llevó a cabo el
encuentro de la jurisdicción especial
para la paz por la verdad del
reconocimiento de las ejecuciones
extrajudiciales en el caso conocido como
'falsos positivos' en la capital bogotá
y su municipio aledaño su hacha
militares retirados han declarado sobre
el asesinato de civiles a quienes
hicieron pasar como guerrilleros para
cumplir metas en la lucha del conflicto
armado según la red hay 6402 casos en al
menos 31 de los 32 departamentos del
país
de esta manera despedimos esta
informativa en france 24 gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]